- We have seen the heart
breaking images from Australia.
Everybody's been probably
keeping up with that
and where the fires have
just devastated that country.
18 million acres burned,
3000 homes were destroyed,
and probably the most
shocking statistic of all,
is up to a billion animals
may have lost their lives,
which is so sad, look at, oh my gosh.
I've watched the news and like all of you,
my heart breaks for
the people of Australia
but where there is tragedy
there are always people that are helping
and including the Irwin family.
They operate the Australia Zoo
which has taken in tens
of thousands of animals,
you might remember I had Bindi, Robert
and Terri on last year.
And so I reached out to them
for an update on their efforts
and how we here in the
U.S. could help in any way.
So they're joining us from Australia.
Might be a little bit of a
delay, it's gonna be great.
Hey everyone, what's going on?
(applause)
Hi, (screams) they're so cute.
Tell us who you have here.
- They are so adorable.
We've got two little flying foxes,
also known as fruit bats.
- Or sky puppies.
They basically are little sky puppies.
And these little ones are orphans.
They are absolutely adorable.
And we've seen hundreds
and hundreds of fruit bats
that've been taken up to
our state of Queensland,
that need rehabilitation
because of the fires that
are happening down south.
- So they were too little
to escape the fires.
So their mommas flew away,
but then they were stuck.
We've gotten about 700
fruit bats up here so far.
- Wow.
So some of the animals you're caring for
are extremely vulnerable, right?
Not just the fruit bats, right?
- Absolutely.
We have so many different species
of Australian wildlife
coming through our doors.
We have koalas that are being treated.
The poor koalas get stuck
in the eucalyptus trees
and the eucalyptus trees
just catch fire instantly.
They almost explode.
And the koalas have nowhere to go.
It's unbelievable.
So thankfully here at the
Australia Zoo Wildlife Hospital,
we have now treated over 90,000 sick,
injured and orphaned animals.
- [Kelly] Way to go.
- And we're doing everything we can
to treat every single animal
(applause)
that comes through our doors.
It's incredibly important.
- So we obviously now
what y'all are doing,
you're, you know, providing
miracles over there
for these animals.
But I know there are a
lot of people in the U.S.
that want to help,
so what's the best way
we can get involved.
Like, where can we spend money,
or where can people in
Australia give time.
What are all those options?
- Sure.
So it's really helpful, if
you want to help wildlife,
to donate to Wildlife Warriors
at wildlifewarriors.org.
We are a charity in the United States,
which means it's a tax
deductible donation,
and then the funds are
transferred to Australia
to help in this emergency time.
So thank you so much.
That way we can send
care packages of medicine
and food to the front line of the fire.
We can help people who are
dealing with transporting animals
up here for help.
And we can get our teams of veterinarians
and technicians down to assist as well.
- [Kelly] Well, thank you so much.
(applause)
- Like, just on the behalf of humanity,
thank you so much for just
doing so much for these animals.
We know that your family loves animals
and just what you're
doing is so important,
it's so inspiring to all of us.
So we have links on our website
for ways people at home can help.
Just be sure to go to
kellyclarksonshow.com for more info.
And Terri, Bindi and Robert,
thank you all so much
again for just what you do.
Good luck,
and thank you so much
for joining us again.
(applause)
- Thank you for being Wildlife Warriors.
- [Kelly] Have a good 2020.
- Thanks Kelly.
- Thank you so much.
We love you.